and I do think there are some remnants
of Truth in their words because they're
scared that what's going to end up
happening throughout the years because
the Game Pass they're start gonna
they're gonna slowly lose that massive
Call of Duty casual place leaving
PlayStation coming to Xbox because if
they don't have to pay for anything it's
hard to tell uh you know the amount of
stuff they can do with the Call of Duty
brand just because they put Call of Duty
doesn't mean they can do little things
on top of just okay we're going to give
you Call of Duty every year but what we
didn't say is
we're gonna give you Call of Duty here
going out now let's and then then you
you you find out a couple years down the
line they remake all the the Black Ops
put them in the collection and they
don't get that there's a lot of
semantics to this that I can understand
where Sony's coming from where it's like
look we don't know the future if we lose
Call of Duty and it could literally
Domino affect them losing a huge Market
a huge uh par part of the market but